Speaker 1: Let's now go and talk about the
Senate. I have to tell you that the Senate
is not looking so bad. Now, we'll look at
the general Senate numbers in a moment,
but there are three prominent Republicans who,
as of right now, are losing their Senate races.
Let's talk about them one by one, first and
foremost. Val Demings, member of Congress,
Democratic member of Congress, former police
officer, she has decided to challenge Marco Rubio,
the incumbent Republican Florida senator, for
his seat. She's currently winning by four.
This could go in any direction between now
and November, but we're only two and a half
months away. And to be such a long time
incumbent senator, is Marco Rubio sort of
a celebrity senator to the extent that he ran
for president and he's more well-known then,
you know, pick whoever Ben Sasse, I don't know
senators whose names I don't even know. And so the
fact that he is down four is not insignificant. As
the Hill reports, Val Demings leads Rubio by four,
according to a poll released Tuesday. The poll is
from University of North Florida's Public Opinion
Research Lab. It shows Deming Demings at 48.
Rubio at 44. 7% saying they would choose someone
else. Now, much of that 7% will ultimately
vote for Demings or Rubio. So that is very,
very interesting. Now, a couple of other races
that are interesting. There is the Mehmet Oz
versus John Fetterman race in Pennsylvania, in
the Senate there. As I've told you before, this
is a race that could decide whether Democrats or
Republicans control the Senate after the November
election. This is not a race that is looking
very good for Mehmet Oz, despite all of his
personal wealth and cringe ads and everything. The
latest Fox News poll has it at Fetterman plus 11.
The Fabrizio Anzalone poll has it at Fetterman
plus six, USA Today, Fetterman Plus nine.
Those aren't particularly new polls, but on
average right now, according to Real Clear
Politics, Fetterman leading odds by on average 8.7
points. That's good news for Democrats as well.
And then lastly in Georgia, and this is a really
scary one because it is way, way, way too close.
In Georgia, incumbent Democratic Senator Raphael
Warnock is trying to beat off a challenge from
Herschel Walker. Herschel Walker is the Republican
nominee who cannot speak, who cannot put together
a coherent sentence, and yet somehow look at
these numbers. WARNOCK Yes, he's leading, but
he is leading by only an average of 4.4 points in
that race. Walker cannot think and cannot speak.
He understands not a single political issue, and
he's almost within the margin of error. That is
endlessly, endlessly horrifying about what it says
about the United States and its electorate. Now,
overall, how are things looking for the fall? If
we look at the FiveThirtyEight forecast in the
Senate, Democrats are now up to a 61% chance of
holding the Senate. This is a number that started
at roughly 50, 50 months ago. And over time, the
scenarios have shifted more and more and more in
favor of Democrats holding the Senate. Now, 61 in
100 doesn't mean Democrats are likely to have 61
seats, not even close. In fact, as you can see
on this graphic, the most likely scenarios are
either another 5050 split with Kamala Harris being
the tie breaking vote, meaning Democrats control
Democrats having 51 seats or 52 seats. Those are
the most likely scenarios, but a 61% chance of
holding the Senate when really Republicans
should be taking it, historically speaking,
is not altogether terrible. And then over in the
House of Representatives, the odds have improved
just marginally for Democrats, but still roughly
a 4 to 1 edge for Republicans. A week or two ago,
I told you that Democrats had only a 20% chance
of winning the House that is just barely inched up
flaccid lee to 22% from 20%. So in all likelihood,
Democrats will lose the House, but if indeed they
maintain the Senate, they will at least be able to
prevent Republicans from doing any serious damage.
Now, also, in terms of the Senate, North Carolina
is in play. Florida, rather, FiveThirtyEight
has North Carolina looking similar to Florida in
terms of the odds that a Democrat takes that seat.
And we are going to continue following all of
these numbers. But the most likely scenario,
the closer we get, the more we can kind
of narrow our prediction. The most likely
outcome right now is Democrats hold the Senate,
lose the House, and we have just vile obstruction
for the next two years and nothing gets done.
And then Republicans use their own obstruction
to try to justify voting for a Republican for
president in 2024 because Joe Biden didn't get
anything done for those last two years, thanks
to them, of course. So that's where we are right
now. I look forward to taking your questions about
the 2022 midterms during our upcoming Member Only
Viewer Townhall. We do many wide open, full
audience viewer townhalls. We are holding an
exclusive event on Wednesday, August 31, at 6
p.m. Eastern Time, where members will be able
to call in and chat with me. We will stream
the event for everybody, but only members will
participate. If you would like to participate,
simply sign up at join Packman dot com